- He's an entrepreneur,
television personality,
real estate magnet and investor.
He was number 17 on Forbes'
2011 Celebrity 100 list.
He even considered running
for President of the
United States of America.
He's Donald Trump,
and here are his top 10 rules for success.
- In your book The Art of the Deal,
you said that money really
isn't that important.
It's just a means of keeping score.
It's playing the game that excites you.
- I love the game.
I like the money and
the money is certainly
a method of keeping score, but
I don't do things for money.
I do things because I enjoy doing them.
That really can sometimes translate
into more money than you would have made
if you weren't just after the money.
Never, ever
give up.
You can change and you can move around
but never ever give up.
I know people that are very smart.
They went to the Wharton
School of Finance with me.
I know other people that aren't as smart
and those people are the top
people in the industry today
and they top, they just were tougher.
They didn't give up.
And the smart ones had
everything on their plate.
They'd always come in with
the A plus on the tests
and the good boards and everything else.
But when they ran into problems,
they did not know how
to solve the problems
like the guys that weren't as good.
And it's very seldom that you see
something other than this happen.
So never ever give up.
A lot of that is all in the details.
You've got to be into the details
because if you're not
they'll come back to haunt you.
So, often times you know,
life is in the details
well business is also in the details.
You have to be very careful,
you have to watch the dotted I's
because you can really lose tremendously
if you don't watch those details.
So we discussed that and
as Robert likes to say
probably more than I do,
that's the little finger.
But it's all about the details.
That's very important.
You want to be totally focused.
You can't take your eye off the ball.
When I had troubles in the early 90's,
a major article came out
and it said very strongly,
everything he touches turns to gold.
And I believed it.
So I would go out with models that night
instead of working
but that wasn't good.
And I remember, I had
a big lease coming up,
there was a big show,
and I went to the show.
I said, don't worry fellas,
you can handle the lease,
you'll get it done.
Well I came back, they didn't get it done,
and I would have had it done 100%.
And then the market crashed in the 90's,
so I had trouble
but it was sort of an amazing,
I wouldn't want to do it again
but it was amazing test of yourself.
Can you handle pressure?
How are you under pressure?
Are you smart?
You know, when everybody's coming at you.
You know, the worst
employee is a good employee.
A bad employee is fine
because you fire that person right away.
A great employee is phenomenal.
You want to keep them and cherish them.
They're fantastic.
But a good employee, you
never sort of fire them.
But they never leave
you to the next level.
They just keep their job.
They're sort of too good to be fired,
but they're not good enough.
You're never going to do great.
So I always say, the worst
employee isn't a bad employee.
It's just a good or average employee.
Gary Player, the great golfer,
he was a little guy, very little,
but he worked really hard
and he had a great statement.
He'd go, the harder I
work, the luckier I get.
And he wins the US Open.
You have all these big handsome guys,
these big giant guys, and
they'd hit the ball a mile,
and you have Gary Player.
And Gary Player would win the Open.
He would win the Masters.
He would win this, he'd win that.
And he said, you know, hey.
In the US Open he hit a five iron
to one foot from the hole
and he ended up getting a birdie
and wins the US Open right.
And he came off the green,
and I know I've heard
this statement before,
but I heard it from him
in a meaningful way.
They said what do you
think Gary, what is it?
He said, all I know is
I've been working very hard
and the harder I work, the luckier I get.
I thought it was an amazing saying.
Sometimes in life to be successful,
often times, most of the time,
you have to follow your instincts.
You have to follow your gut.
You have to.
Your parents may say wrong.
Your whoever may say wrong.
But you have to do it.
So much of success is seeing
yourself as victorious.
You have to see yourself,
you have to really believe in yourself.
And sometimes it's hard.
You know, you've had failures,
you've had weaknesses,
you've had other things.
You have to see yourself
as a one man band.
Don't rely too much on other people
because they'll let ya down.
You have to see yourself as victorious.
And to be a winner you have
to think like a winner.
If you don't think like a winner,
it's just never going to happen.
Many people have been
asking about my desk,
and the fact that I have
so many papers on my desk.
It's actually very neat, I
know where everything is.
But if you look around, I
mean, there's a lot of stuff.
The fact is, I'm very busy.
I always noticed that busy people,
people that are very
successful in many cases,
have a lot going on on their desk.
I have papers from deals.
I have papers from just about everything.
I like to read up on things.
I like to study what I'm doing.
So therefore, you have
a lot of action going on
in your office.
Now, some of the writers,
some of the ones that aren't so smart,
they talk about the desk negatively.
They say oh isn't it terrible.
Trump has so many papers on his desk.
Let's analyze everything on the desk
and they do their best and they fail.
But the fact is, I've
noticed over the years,
successful people have a
lot going on on their desk.
My desk is in my office,
my desk is a very important part of me,
and frankly, it's a very
important part of my success.
Everything I do comes
right through this desk.
So, if it's not perfectly neat,
if there's a lot of action,
I think that's okay.
I actually think that's a good thing.
You have to love what you do.
And I'm not going to go over that long,
but it solves a lot of problems,
because when you love what you do
when you really love what you do,
you work harder.
I mean I have friends that don't love
and I tell this story,
a Wall Street type, big guy,
but I was richer than him and
I'm richer according to Forbes
I am much richer than him,
so I like that, you know
I like that.
But this big Wall Street
guy and he's a big man,
he has a son,
and his son is a wonderful human being
which is amazing because
the guy's a horrible
horrible person.
But he's one of the biggest
guys on Wall Street.
So he wants his son Alex,
I'm going to use the name
Alex, it's not his name,
but I don't want to get
this guy in any more trouble
with his father than he already is.
Alex isn't the strongest character.
The father is a brutal vicious killer.
So the father, has a
big firm on Wall Street
and he wants Alex to go
into the firm of course.
You know, come on Alex,
get in there, get in there.
And in the meantime, all
these kids are graduating
from Wharton and Harvard and Stanford
and they're just eating Alex's lunch.
He doesn't have a chance,
he doesn't have a chance.
And he doesn't like it.
He's not liking what he's doing.
You got to love what you do.
He's not liking it.
So one day, but he can't
leave because of his father,
I actually told him, why don't you leave!
Your father's brutal!
The father's just killing
the guy telling him
you don't have what it takes.
I'm sorry dad.
Oh this is great, so I say
you got to leave the father.
You got to leave him.
He said I just can't Donald.
So anyway, he's a spoiled guy.
He's a member of a very good
golf club in Westchester,
which is a rich place in New York.
And he's on one of the committees,
he's on the greens committee.
And they put him in charge
of redoing the course
and doing this big
renovation of the course.
It's a very good club
and he's there every morning
at five in the morning.
He doesn't leave.
He did such an unbelievable job.
The contractors respected him,
everybody respected him.
So the wife comes up, he's
doing so great Donald,
he's so amazing.
And they give him an honor.
And this is a tough group of people
that have this club.
You know, they're club
members and they're difficult.
They gave him an honor.
The club came in under
budget, faster by two months.
He did an unbelievable job
and the quality of the work was ten times
what they ever anticipated.
So they gave him a medal.
I said, you know, Alex, if you were to go
and do this for a living,
you ought to be a builder.
Whether it's houses, or
clubs, or golf courses,
renovations or this.
Oh my father would go
crazy, he'd never let me.
So Alex went back to Wall
Street where he was miserable.
And a year later, he quit.
And he started doing renovations of houses
and clubs and different
things, and he's doing great.
So, you've got to love what you do.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Anuj Deben asked me to.
I hope I pronounced that properly.
So if there's a video
that you want me to make
on a famous entrepreneur,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what
you think of Donald Trump.
Do you love him, do you hate him?
Leave it below, I'm going
to join the discussion
and I look forward to
hearing what you have to say.